حدث وضرب سد نوفاكخوفكا في منطقه خيرسون
جنوبيه اوكرانيا ويحدث ايضا ان المياه
تغمر ما في طريقها وفي طريقها تتبادل
موسكو الاتهامات
الرئيس الاوكراني سارع الى القاء اللوم في
الهجوم على من وصفهم بالارهابيين الروس
ودعا الى طرد روسيا من اوكرانيا
واتهمت القياده الجنوبيه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه القوات الروسيه بتفجير السد
مدير مكتب الرئاسه الاوكراني اعتبر تدمير
السد جريمه حرب جديده وتشكل تهديدا لمحطه
زبروجيا النوويه وتهديد الاف السكان جنوبي
خرسون اما عمده مدينه نوفاكاخوفكا الموالي
لروسيا اتهم القوات الاوكرانيه بقصف السد
في المدينه فيما رجحت السلطات المحليه
المواليه لروسيا ان القصف تم براجمات
صواريخ لكن من المستفيد يقول الجيش
الاوكراني ان هدف روسيا من استهداف السد
هو تعطيل العمليات الهجوميه بزياده منسوب
نهر دنيبرو ما يصعب العبور للضفه التي
تسيطر عليها روسيا في حين يقول الكرملين
ان اوكرانيا تعمدت استهداف السد لقطع
امدادات المياه شبه جزيره القرم والتغطيه
على فشل هجماتها المضاده الاخيره وفيما
فتحت روسيا تحقيقا جنائيا بعد انفجار سد
نوفا كخوفكا دعت اوكرانيا مجلس الامن
الدولي الى اجتماع طارئ بشان ذلك ايضا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات